frédéric la presse n'est vraiment pas
tout seul là dedans il ya beaucoup
d'autres journaux qui ont déjà migré
vers le web et e comment est-ce qu'il
s'en sorte comment est-ce qu'il survive
mais le mot survivre est bien choisie en
fait le premier journal qu'il a fait aux
etats-unis c'est le seattle post
intelligencer qui est sûr en fait la
côte ouest américaine journal qui
existait depuis 1863 et en 2009 ils ont
dit il faut qu'on change la formule donc
on va sur le web on est passé de 165
journalistes à 20 donc vraiment ils
continuent de vivoter même chose
également pour le roi qui mentent news
au colorado
là aussi on a changé complètement la
formule en 2009 on est allé sur le web
christian science monitor quand même un
grand journal a scellé coûté aux états
unis on est juste sur le web maintenant
donc la formule fonctionne mais c'est
pas encore ça on est vraiment loin des
années noires
le détail des lignes aux délits presse
ça a duré une semaine seulement qu'il
était complètement rayé de la carte
un bon exemple par contre c'est celui du
times picayun de la nouvelle orléans où
là on avait décidé de d'aller sur le web
de les délaisser un petit peu le côté
écrit finalement ils ont décidé de
revenir en arrière 7 jours sur 7
maintenant il publie à l'écrit il savait
quand même pas si mal finalement
bon évidemment il ya des journaux qui
ont qui sont sur le web mais qui ont
gardé une copie papier on peut penser
par exemple l'un des grands quotidiens
évidemment journal vraiment majeurs
jusqu'à un certain point avait 1200
journalistes donc toujours en version
papier mais aussi beaucoup sur le web
ils ont choisi la formule du pétrole
donc c'est le verrou d'accès payant donc
après certain nombre d'articles en fait
il faut payer il faut s'abonner
est ce que ça marche c'est difficile à
savoir parce que dans le fond il évalue
que ils ont eu jusqu'ici à peu près un
million d'abonnés numériques
si on calcule à peu près 180 5 dollars
par abonné ça fait 185 millions de
revenus ça paraît beaucoup mais pour
repérer en fait pour faire fonctionner
journal ça prend plus d'un milliard
alors il ya encore beaucoup de choses
qui manquent et le pétrole s'est pas
toujours la meilleure formule non plus
en fait le toronto star a décidé de
l'abandonner complètement et d'aller
gratuitement sur les tablettes comme la
presse vient de le faire
oui si aujourd'hui qui commence à
exactement première journée il ya
d'autres modèles par contre comme celui
qui explore en ce moment leur unique
free press ouais ça c'est à paris que le
flux presse a pris ces deux on y va avec
le micro-paiement c'est un peu comme
itunes ou de chez rapport plutôt que
d'acheter à l'album au complet dans
artiste on va juste choisir une chanson
pour 99 cents c'est la même chose pour
le free press vous aimez un article vous
le payez et puis c'est tout donc là
évidemment ça va probablement encore
plus fragmenté le lectorat c'est
difficile de fidéliser
d'autant plus qu'il ya beaucoup de
concurrence il ya des médias comme par
exemple weiss news or affectés aux
postes qu'ils continuent de manger des
parts de marché donc ce n'est pas facile
pour les journaux ça c'est pour les gens
noé pour ceux qui aiment les gens nés et
voilà merci